hey guys so wheat for has happened this
means that my exams are now scary to
close this week has been almost entirely
spent in the library much like last week
after I think if we're gonna notice the
pattern as these books go on throughout
the term in the world of work though I
did have one final outing out of the
library and that was to my last lecture
ever as an undergraduate boxford which
is a bit kind of sad to think about
actually it was really cool it was a
good one to finish on so it was an
atmospheric physics lecture and
basically a lot about astrophysics is to
do with fluid dynamics and not just
atmospheric physics oceanic physics
which is what we've been doing recently
and so the professor's have got together
some laboratory equipment and did some
demonstrations for us but like I said
most of this week has been spending in
the library sat down with my notes
making notes doing problem sheets again
we've started to do some exam questions
and as such it's kind of difficult to me
sitting in the library for eight or nine
hours a day interesting to talk about
and vlog so I'm gonna try something a
little bit different this week so Jamie
last week talked about college marriages
which is a sort of very unique Oxford
thing and basically I thought I'd do
something similar but with a different
topic so I thought as a public service I
would say if you're in confusion you
have when you come up here and to an
Oxford glossary toot now short for a
tutorial one of these things that nobody
ever says they're gonna use when they
first come up there everybody ends up
using it basically a tutorial is the
kind of hallmark of the Oxford education
system so it's a one on one or one two
sometimes one on four time with your
tutor so typically for a science subject
you will have a problem sheet with your
the chapter in the week you'll hand it
in say on a Friday and on Monday you'll
sit down with your tutor for an hour
going through the questions and they'll
give you back a Marx script most of the
time and you will talk about the
questions that you found difficult and
you'll probably go through them on board
matriculation matriculation is the act
of formally becoming a member of the
University and involves going to your
matriculation ceremony which would take
place here in the showed only in theatre
where you get to wear your gown and your
sub busk more on that in a minute and
you listen to the vice-chancellor read
something out in Latin and then you
become a full member of the university
after matriculation also comes
matriculation
you'd probably guess what that is sub
fusca coming from the Latin for on the
dark or dusky color sub fast prefers the
full more dress that you wear as a
member the university so you were self
asked idea matriculation we also wear at
your exams and for guys a bus consists
of a dark suit white shirt white bowtie
a gown and a carrot multiple whisper
girls it's black skirt white blouse gown
and I'd actually don't you call it but
it's kind of like a girly version of a
bowtie like it's like a ribbon that your
time point is called a ribbon tab a tab
is a student at Cambridge commonly used
in conjunction with the adjective filthy
getting deemed getting deemed is nowhere
near as fun as it sounds like it
basically means getting in trouble with
your colleges Dean this is normally
because you're part of a sports club
which has caused a bit too much noise on
one of its night out or have caused a
mess somewhere probably also on one of
your nights out and most him on the
subject to things that Jamie's done and
Jamie generally I met him in my college
bar and he was just visiting some
friends but we were talking about
something which one of you left in the
comment section on a previous video I
think he was actually last week's vlog
which is that we should do a
collaboration video so we're breve up
for doing this for this week's question
I'd love that if you guys could leave in
the comment section suggestions for what
we could do as a video we were thinking
of some kind of Top Gear style challenge
in Oxford maybe involving like a punt
race or something I don't know but what
whatever you guys think would be cool
leave in the comments section and up
vote each other's suggestions if you
like the sound of them just as a quick
note by the way before are you finished
I've been receiving a lot of friend
requests and people who watch these
vlogs I'm one happy on Facebook and I
just wanna be absolutely clear that I
keep my Facebook personal it's it's I
don't have people that I don't know IRL
however if you do want to have something
to do with me then you're very welcome
to follow me I added that feature on my
Facebook which you can do but I just
like it if you guys could respect me
wanting to keep it private basically and
lastly basically exam season started and
so I want to give you guys some fair
warning that these videos are probably
gonna deteriorate in length quality and
interestingness as the term goes on so
please be understanding that basically
I'm not responding to messages
I'm not replies that when you comment
at the moment just because I don't have
the time and yeah physics happened
basically so I'm sorry that these vlogs
including this one aren't necessarily
give me as interesting but dig there
with me so normal service will be
resumed after exams and thanks for
sticking around I really do it's meant a
lot to me to have you guys coming back
every week and leaving lovely comments
on my videos it's been a real boost to
me so thank you very much for stickier
and I apologize that I'm gonna go a bit
mental
leave suggestions for what you'd like me
Jaime to do in a collaboration video in
the comments below
Jaime I will see you on Thursday I'll
see you guys on something